[Music]
W it's a box Fit For A King it is as it
should be we're delivering it to the
king of space himself a real life King
this could be my big chance to
[Music]
gravel ooh Swanky
dump your delivery my
leash now this guy knows how to gravel
yes at last the portrait of my late wife
has arrived careful it's
[Music]
delicate infinita queen of space not
even the finest macaroni artist could
capture your beauty although this one
did hang it over
there sorry it's my early onset
sciatica announc sing his Royal Highness
the prince of space allow me to help
your elderly
friend wow this absolute stud sure made
me look like a wimp huh Leela you guys
straighten that together while I explain
our loyalty punch card program to his
[Music]
majesty